the national museum of african american
history and culture puts forth an
anti-racist display that sounds
kind of like white supremacy ilhan omar
complains that everyone is a racist and
president trump changes his campaign
manager
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a write to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com
ben so yesterday just kind of trolling
around on twitter as per our usual
arrangement and i came across this
insane display
from the national museum of african
american history and culture and it
really does speak
to our bizarre cultural moment because
the fact is that the new anti-racist
movement the sort of ibram candy robin
d'angelo
anti-racist movement that has become so
popular on the left that has really
overwhelmed the old version of what
racism was racism used to be defined as
we've been talking about
as you believe in the supremacy or
inferiority of a group based on
characteristics they cannot control like
skin color this was defined as white
supremacy or as racism depending on who
was being the racist and who was being
the victim
well that has now been changed too the
entire system is racist and if you are
complicit in any system that produces
inequality
then you are part of the problem and you
are a racist and to be anti-racist you
have to fight the system well this sort
of idea
has now been promulgated with your
taxpayer dollars at the national museum
of african-american history and culture
a project
of the smithsonian institution and i
want to go through the display that they
put forth because
not only is it hideous and horrifying
it's overtly racist against black
americans i mean that is what it is it's
incredible
it's incredible like you cannot
distinguish the verbiage
on this poster from anything david duke
would say it's impossible
to actually tell the difference because
in the end what it suggests is that all
the hallmarks
that make a person or culture or
civilization successful are white things
right david duke would say this in order
to tell white people the national museum
of african american history and culture
is saying this in order to downgrade the
quote unquote standards
of success and this has real
ramifications because
when we look at problems in american
society we look at problems like
police brutality or if we look at
problems like income gaps between black
americans and white americans and
educational gaps between black americans
and white americans
these are specific problems with
specific solutions are these there are
things we can do
about some of these things there are
things we can't do about some of these
things but
if politics is the solutions business
right politics is the place you're
supposed to go
to discuss a problem and then come up
with an answer that is the goal of
politics is solution making but our
politics these days has become more
about feelings
i've said before on the show i've talked
about this that when my wife and i first
got married
and when you first get married there are
always some bumps that you have to iron
out thank god my wife and i have an
incredible
marriage married 12 years now with three
kids very happy but
at the very beginning there was a sort
of situation that would continually
arise and the situation was my wife
would come to me with a problem
and i being a doting husband would say
okay let's talk about
the solution and she'd get upset because
it turns out that what she didn't want
was the solution what she actually
wanted was for me to just hear her
hear her feelings right she wanted me to
show that i cared about her experiences
and this made no sense to me because i
am a solutions oriented person
and so i i literally had to say to her
sweetheart i need you to tell me upfront
in the conversation
whether this is a a conversation where
you just want me to show sympathy or is
this a con i'm kind of a robot this way
or is this a conversation
where you want me to provide a solution
well politics is supposed to be all
about the latter right it's also
supposed to be about solutions
but virtually none of politics in modern
america is about solutions and in fact
if you offer solutions to any of these
problems
if you suggest that maybe a solution to
the income gap is to
culturally press forward with the cause
of less single motherhood
if you suggest that maybe one of the
things we should do is push school
vouchers
maybe one of the things we should do is
push standards of education
inside homes that value education more
if you suggest
that maybe one of the things we ought to
do is put more police officers in high
crime areas so as to crack down on crime
and provide a safe haven for businesses
and investment that raises the tax base
increases the funding for public schools
and provides jobs for more people then
you are part of the problem
you see the politics is if you mention
if you're senator tim scott and you come
forward with a bill
that is meant to take the first steps
toward curbing police brutality
you are hit with more vitriol by the
left than if you had never provided any
sort of solution at all because the
solution
is not the point the complaining is the
point the castigation of the entire
system is the point
shoring up the system is the problem if
you shore up the system then all you are
doing is
merely supporting a system of brutality
and racism
and cruelty now that is not a recipe for
a future for the country there cannot be
a future to a country that basically
suggests that any time there is a
problem
if you try to solve it you yourself are
part of the problem
that is a that is a movement that is
destined to destroy the country
this is what my new book is about how to
destroy america in three easy steps out
next tuesday
you can get it at amazon or you can buy
a signed copy at dailywire.com it's all
about this it's all about the quest to
destroy america with a vision of america
that sees america as pure power politics
and the system itself as as an indicator
of hierarchical brutality and this is
something that the the left is pushing
these days very hard and now
it is being embedded in cultural
institutions so first of all i think
most americans
should be able to look at this and say
this is ridiculous but most americans i
think are not
looking at this anti-racist you know the
new definition of anti-racist which is
to say
disestablishmentarianism get rid of the
system they're not looking at this and
saying this is ridiculous
they've been so trained to treat any
accusation of racism as gospel
that they are willing to even hear the
redefinition of racism even if it means
that they are supposed to now silence
themselves silence their common sense
tear down the system that provides them
the opportunity for a
civilized and wonderful life that's how
powerful the charge of racism has become
you can even shift the definition of
racism
and people will still be so cowed by the
very word with a completely different
definition
that they will go along to get along so
here is the new definition
of whiteness and racism get ready for
this because it's amazing and this is
from
taxpayer sponsored national museum of
african american history and culture
aspects and assumptions of whiteness and
white culture in the united states is a
full poster
white dominant culture or whiteness
refers to the ways white people and
their traditions
attitudes and ways of life have been
normalized over time and are now
considered standard practices in the
united states
and since white people still hold most
of the institutional power in america
we all have internalized some aspects of
white culture including people of color
so in other words if you're a black
person and you believe in any of the
following list that we're going to get
to in a second
any of the following principles if
you're black and you believe this it's
because on the inside you're white
you've now turned into an oreo right
that is the
really this is what this is saying it is
saying that you if you have internalized
any of the things i'm about to explain
to you then it is because you have now
internalized whiteness
you have now suffered from
assimilationism as ibrahim kennedy
suggests in how to be
an anti-racist okay here are some of the
things that are associated with
whiteness
and white dominant culture okay these
are some of the things and again i
challenge you to tell me how this is
anything different from what david duke
would say
the former grand wizard of the kkk
rugged individualism
is about white dominant culture or
whiteness the individual as the primary
unit
self-reliant independence and autonomy
highly valued and rewarded
individuals assumed to be in control of
their environment you get what you
deserve
so individualism itself is just a white
thing
if you believe that you have agency in
your own life which by the way is the
precondition to any success in this life
or any other
if you believe that you have the power
to shape your own future
that is your whiteness talking that is
your internalized whiteness
because only white people have
historically had such power except for
the fact that now everybody has that
power in the united states and legally
has had that power
since the civil rights act of 1964. okay
other things that are aspects
of whiteness in the united states family
structure
that's a white thing again this is
according to the national museum of
african american history
and culture family structure is a white
thing the nuclear family
is a white thing wife as homemaker
husband as breadwinner
children as independent and that they
should have their own rooms apparently
if your kids have their own rooms it's
because it's a white thing which is real
weird
because when i was growing up i shared a
room with all three of my sisters until
i was 11 years old so i guess we weren't
white then so that's that's kind of
strange
emphasis on scientific method is a white
thing
i'm not kidding it says this this is a
museum okay the museum is saying
that if you believe in the scientific
method it's because it's a white thing
that you have internalized
objective rational linear thinking is a
white thing
cause and effect relationships are a
white thing quantitative emphasis
is a white thing data analysis basically
if you think like a rational human being
it's because you've internalized
whiteness
okay this is the most racist thing in
the entire world this is basically
suggesting
that if it were not for white people
there would be no rationality
rationality would not exist
there's not been a single brown person
steeped in their own culture in human
history
who thought in a linear quantitative
cause and effect way
which is bizarre historical and insane
okay if you if you emphasize the
scientific method that's only because
you're white
david duke could have i'm telling you
david could have written this because
david dukes like you know what's great
about white people
individualism their scientific thinking
their brains
right because david duke's a racist okay
this is a racist document but it's
masquerading as an anti-racist document
and i'll explain why in a second okay
other things that are white if you
mention western civilization
that's a white thing because western
civilization is not important
apparently in the broad view of humanity
despite the fact that western civilized
valleys have now taken over
most of humanity and have been
responsible for the uplift and freeing
of billions of human beings
a heavy focus on the british empire in
history is a white thing because
apparently the british empire was not
important except for the fact that
the sun literally never set on the
british empire so there was that it was
kind of an important part of human
history
work ethic the protestant work ethic is
a white thing
hard work as the key to success is a
white thing
it is a is a an aspect of white dominant
culture if you believe that you should
work hard
and you should work before you play i
i'm serious
these are white things according to this
museum not kidding
also delayed gratification is a white
thing if you're oriented toward the
future now again
every aspect here everything i'm talking
about these are the preconditions for
success in any free system
being a person who focuses on the future
delayed gratification hard work rugged
individualism a belief in data and
science like these are the preconditions
to success in a free country
these are being labeled white things and
if you believe in them
you have internalized the white culture
other things that they say are white
are things like value on ownership of
goods space and property which okay
just the utter insanity of suggesting
that only white people have ever valued
ownership of goods space and property
really why are there tribal chiefs in
literally every civilization ever known
to man and they are the richest most
powerful people why
if you follow rigid time schedules if
you view time as
if you are punctual that is a white
thing being punctual is a white thing
apparently if you believe in english
common law
and protecting private property if you
believe that intent counts injustice
if you believe that there is a
difference between manslaughter and
first degree murder
if you believe that people should have
to show intent to be blamed
fully for a crime then this is
this is the then this is an aspect of
whiteness and finally decision making if
you make decisions
if you salute if you are oriented
towards solutions if you must always do
something about situation
that means that you are oriented toward
whiteness i'm going to get into more of
this and what exactly this means
and how this destroys the country and
how woke white people bowing to this
bull crap
how how these woke white people are
destroying the country it really is
insane
i'll get to that in just a moment first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you probably heard me talk
about my helix mattress okay i love my
helix slit mattress it is the only thing
that allows me to get through the day
since my children have decided to wake
me up
at all hours of the night well good news
helix has now gone beyond the bedroom
they've started
making sofas they just launched a new
company it's called all form they're
making premium customizable sofas and
chairs
shipped directly to your door they are
just gorgeous i mean these are beautiful
pieces of furniture
what makes an all formula really cool
well for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you pick your fabric it is spill
stain and scratch resistant as i said i
have kids that is vital
the sofa color the color of the leg sofa
size shape you make sure it's perfect
for you or your home they've got arm
chairs
love seats all the way up to eight seat
sectionals and there's something for
everyone and you can start small and you
can bolt on additional pieces
of your sofa can always change and grow
as your house changes and grow
all form sofas are delivered directly to
your home fast free shipping in the past
if you wanted to order a sofa it could
take weeks or even months to arrive not
anymore now it takes three to seven
days to arrive in the mail and you can
assemble it yourself really easily we
did it ourselves at my house i have it
all formed so if i've got the three seat
sofa with chase in the sand color with
espresso legs it is
it is a real addition to my home my kids
love it i love it if getting a sofa
without trying it in store sounds risky
don't worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free and they
will give you a full refund they've also
got a forever warranty like literally
forever for all time
check them out right now at allforum.com
ben and they're offering 20 off all
orders that's a great deal all form.com
slash ben again allform.com for 20
off i promise you're going to love it
the sofa it's just fantastic okay so
what the hell is all of this about right
what in the world are people doing here
the notion that you're going to
castigate as white all of the hallmarks
of success
right being oriented towards solutions
being oriented towards delayed
gratification
being punctual focusing in on elements
of common law like
protection of private property and
intention in criminality
emphasis on the scientific method what
good
how is that helping the world to label
all of that stuff white what does that
mean
well to understand this you really have
to read the idiocy of ibram kendi who's
been
held up as some sort of great thinker
and who indeed must have been dropped on
his head multiple times as a child
because that is the only way i can
really support
the notion that this was in any way
related to rationality i have
a simple rule a line is called handling
razor a tribute to stupidity that which
you cannot attribute
to malice okay well you know the fact is
that if i i actually don't think cabron
kenny's a dumb guy
so it's hard for me to attribute his
perspective to simple being
simple stupidity or simple blindness if
i were going to say that it was
malicious and that it were a plan
honestly if i don't like conspiracy
theories and so i'm not going to i'm not
going to
support one here if there were to be a
conspiracy theory it would sound
something like this
that there are people out there who
actively want to make people's lives
worse so as to be able to blame the
system for people's lives being worse
and then tear it down
right that would be the simple sort of
cloud pivot conspiracy theory here i
don't think that's what's happening i
think people just have a perverse view
of the system and they will use any
brick back in
brickbat in order to hit it they'll use
any crowbar to tear it down
so here is what i mean abram candy in
his ridiculous book how to be an
anti-racist which is
purely crazy he argues that racism is
not in fact a belief in the inherent
superiority or inferiority
of a particular race you should know by
the way robin d'angelo who i've reviewed
at length
robin deangelo is just a white knock-off
of ibrahim kennedy
kendy says that racism is an embedded
system that results in racial inequality
in other words any system that results
in racial inequality is a bad system
which is weird because every system in
human history results in some level of
racial inequality because literally if
you take two groups
and you divide them just with a random
line there will be inequalities between
the two groups statistically
it does not like this is a fact of stats
averages do not actually measure
what happens when you draw a line down
the middle of a room right if we took
all of my employees
and we drew a line down the middle of
the room there would be differences in
in
sexual orientation in gender in race in
income level in height right that's just
the way that it works
you couldn't just average them and say
okay generic blob of humanity
because of that there will always be
racial inequalities because bottom line
is that
any group division means there will be
differences in group and by the way
one of the things that i always notice
about people who talk about racial
inequality in the united states
is that they always target the system
the evil terrible no good very bad
american system
if you were going to write an equation
here i go with my scientific thinking
again
aspects of whiteness and all of this if
you're going to write an equation
about inequality and you're going to
have the
the statistical inequality and then the
independent variable
meaning the thing that changes so most
thinkers of the left
will simply suggest that the independent
variable is america america is
america's policies are responsible and
therefore the only differences
in inequality is the american system but
in order to say that that's the
independent variable shouldn't you have
some sort of comparative analysis of
whether there is racial inequality in
other systems
if you're going to say that america is
the problem really you should look at
other systems and determine whether
racial inequality persists in other
systems
and the answer of course is yes black
americans are significantly better
off on a household income level for
example than black canadians or black
britishers
or black french okay that is a simple
statistical analysis to do
racial inequalities exist in canada they
are very large they exist in britain
they are very large they exist across
europe
they're very large they're they're
inequalities across africa right
this is just a common aspect of humanity
is racial inequality so blaming it on
america you're going to need to do a
little bit better
than just the simple assumption that all
systems that produce inequality
are evil americanism but this is ibrahim
kendy's suggestion which is completely
afactual
now the good news is he's also labeled
science racist so that means that if you
question him with science then that
means that you are just
exhibiting your white supremacy or
something it's completely unfalsifiable
right you make a prop you make a
propositional statement about
the world and if i say the science
doesn't back that you say well science
is a white people thing
that's what interim kennedy's doing here
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one second i'll explain what exactly is
going on and how all of these woke white
people in an attempt
to buy their way out of racist jail
right faux racist jail they're willing
to do any sort of virtue signaling they
can
it at least some pretty bizarre results
we'll get to that in just a moment first
hiring can be difficult but if you are
currently hiring you face new
difficulties these days
housing wire could relate they needed to
hire a reporter to cover news stories on
the us housing market so they turned to
zip recruiter and that is how housing
wire found alexandra roja alexandra
never imagined
she could get a reporter job during
covet 19. she created a profile on zip
recruiter and sure enough
she ended up working over at housing
wire zip recorder is a great way for
employers to find
employees that is why we use zipper
critter ourselves also it makes a great
way for me to be able to threaten my
employees
if they don't do their jobs they know
they could be next on the zip recruiter
ad
they know that their job could be filled
like this boom you could fill that job
in fact go check out zip recruiter right
now if you're an employee looking for a
great employer or if you're a great
employer or looking for an employee
zip recruiter is the place to go see how
zipperclear can help you hire try it now
for free
at ziprecruiter.com ben that's
ziprecruiter.com
go check them out right now
ziprecruiter.com ben
and go check them out right this very
moment and i promise you you will be
happy that you did
you'll be upgrading your employment
situation immeasurably by checking out
ziprecruiter
right now ziprecruiter.com slash ben
okay so
back to ibram county so abram kenzie
says that any system that results in
racial inequality
is a racist system any complicity in
that system is racist also because
silence is violence right so anti-racism
means opposition to such systems
here's what kennedy says in his in his
dumb book quote to be anti-racist is to
reject
cultural standards and level cultural
differences
okay now this is a pretty radical
statement and so i've said before
and if you're gonna look at inequality
you do have to look at factors in
personal choice and you have to look at
differences in culture
right if you have one culture that
values education this is not a racial
statement there are values in white
america that
there are certain cultures in white
america that do not value education
jd vance talks about them eloquently and
he'll billiology if you have a culture
that doesn't value education the same
way as another
culture that values education that is
going to have some pretty significant
ramifications for how your children are
educated for example
and if you have a culture that presses
forward with single motherhood as
opposed to pressing for
the nuclear family that's going to have
ramifications for the next generation
ibram kennedy says if you say that there
are differences between cultures
not their differences between races
differences between races on the pure
basis of race that's racism
differences between culture on the basis
that cultures are different which is
perfectly obvious to everyone
right even even the diversity crowd
acknowledges their differences in
culture
they just say that any system that does
not end with an equal result
despite the cultures is a racist system
so kenny literally writes to be
anti-racist is a direct quote is to
reject
cultural standards and level cultural
differences segregationists say racial
groups cannot reach their superior
cultural standard
assimilationists say racial groups can
with effort and intention
reach their superior cultural standards
in fact says kendy
civilization is often a polite euphemism
for cultural racism
now cultural racism is a conflict in
terms that's a conflict in terms
racism is about race culture is about
culture so by conflating culture with
race what he's essentially saying is no
matter what decisions you make in life
no matter what things you value we
should end up in the same place if the
system
were fair which is totally insipid it's
utterly crazy
so kenny is indicting systems that
produce progress and wealth and
happiness
but that like all free systems also
result in inequality
so what this means is that any system
that results in inequality
we don't we don't have to look at your
personal action we don't have to look at
what you did we don't have to look at
your personal choice in fact if we do
that is just our whiteness talking this
is how you end up with the bizarre
proclamation that individualism and
individual choice is a white person
thing
which again is something david duke
likes had something david duke agrees
with
but this is now being promulgated at the
highest levels by our nation's
newspapers
by our colleges by our museums okay
this ends in utter unsuccess it's not
just stupid by the way it's incredibly
dangerous because what you're saying to
people is all the things that you can do
to succeed in life
are now foreclosed to you you should not
do them
it makes you a sellout it makes you an
assimilationist
right the idea is that things like hard
work individualism family structure
thinking about the future delayed
gratification
those are the systems that have created
unprecedented wealth for black americans
the system that martin luther king was
fighting for was access to this system
for black americans not destruction of
the system
he was saying we need more access to the
system and he was right is what booker t
washington was arguing
it's what frederick douglass was arguing
the promises of the declaration must be
extended to all of us
was the argument not the declaration is
evil all of it has to come down and no
matter what choices i make i should have
exactly the same outcome as the guy next
door to me
it creates an unfalsifiable standard
because no system is going to end with
equality when you remove
all human choice and all human agency
from the equation that's utterly nuts
so in essence what this isn't it's not
just rejecting good ideas
as racist it is damning black americans
to lack of success by pushing against
every
possible variable that would militate in
favor of success if you stand for a
nuclear family if you stand for
education and hard work and
individualism if you stand for the
notion that you should delay
gratification
you are being a white person you're
being complicit in the system of racism
how does rejecting family structure make
any black life better
how single motherhood is the single
greatest reason for income inequality by
studies
how does rejecting hard work pay off for
black americans the answer is it doesn't
how does trashing the scientific method
provide an avenue of success for black
americans the answer is it doesn't this
is all about trashing the system
it's all about trashing the system
that's all it is and the sad part is
that white people are going along with
it simply because they are so afraid
that somebody is going to shout at them
racist with no basis whatsoever that's
how powerful the charge has become
you can completely shift what racist
means and shout the same word
and people will still react by saying
okay what do i have to do to make you
stop calling me that
and that's what we are seeing right now
i'm going to read a piece from the
washington post in just a second
that is all about this bizarre bizarre
situation and it is
crazy it's crazy we'll get to it in just
a moment first
we're home a little bit more than usual
these days it is still hard to keep a
close eye on things
i know around my neighborhood there's
been a spate of people robbing mailboxes
well
one way that this can stop is if you get
ring devices you can tell what's
happening
outside your home ring is on a mission
to make neighborhoods safer their home
security products are designed to give
you peace of mind around the clock
from video doorbells and security
cameras to smart security lighting and
alarm systems
ring has everything you need to make
sure your family and belongings are safe
and secure anytime
anywhere with the all-new ring video
doorbell 3 you can keep an even closer
eye on things than ever before
ring will give you protection at every
corner video doorbells that let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime
you can keep an eye on your doorstep or
speak to delivery people when you can't
come to the door
with outdoor security cameras you can
check in on every part of your house and
never miss a moment
smart lighting will brighten up blind
spots make sure you always come home to
that brightly lit house i rely on ring
systems to keep my family safe and you
know if i do
you should too because i'm deeply
concerned with my own family safety
we've had threats before
and ring helps us out with all that sort
of stuff get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit when you go to ring.com
ben that welcome kit includes the ring
video doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's
what you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring.com
again that is ring.com underlying all of
this by the way on
underlying all the faux sympathy from
the white wolf liberals on this sort of
stuff
is a really racist perception of black
americans that black americans cannot
succeed
right ibrahim kenzie in in his in his
book when he talks about this sort of
stuff
abram kenzie makes the distinction
between what he calls the
segregationists
and the assimilationists the
simulationists are people who say if you
work hard within the system you will
succeed
which is true and the segregation is
other people see no matter how hard you
work within the system
you cannot succeed the only thing that
separates the segregation is from ibram
candy is he wants to destroy the system
well there are a lot of white woke
liberals who actually have this bizarre
vision of black americans that they
cannot succeed within the system for
some reason they think that all black
americans are living in abject poverty
in the united states when they are not
the typical black family in the united
states is not living in abject poverty
the median household income for black
americans is nearly 60 000
a year that is not the poverty line the
vast majority
of black americans are middle class or
above
and they are not living in abject
poverty but
again this image has been promulgated by
the media it's been promulgated by the
left that everybody
who is black in america is living in
squalor and it's just not true
okay but what this generates the the
charge of racism is so powerful in
american life because of course
there were a lot of racists in american
history and because america did have an
embedded racist system of segregation in
jim crow
because of all that the charge holds
power even if you are now lying about
the charge
and so this has driven white people to
new depths of insanity
there's a piece over at the washington
post today that is just crazy it's
called stumbling
toward wokeness after george floyd's
death she wanted to be anti-racist
but what would that mean exactly it's
the profile of a woman named christine
tell by robert samuels and it's all
about
it's all about this white woke lady in
tulsa trying to figure out her own
whiteness the text messages were flying
into christine's hotel's cell phone they
were coming
from a group of friends who taught with
her at a preschool inside the methodist
chapel near the green fields of the
university of tulsa
a woman on our facebook post is claiming
we are white's only school one woman
wrote about the interaction on facebook
someone tell me what i'm missing
once looked at the post she knew exactly
what was missing photos of black and
brown students
all of the smiling children featured on
the school's post were white which the
teachers insisted was a coincidence
so far from the truth one responded
noting some of the children in the post
were hispanic
this pisses me off at another dumb said
a third tell tried to figure out a right
way to contribute to the conversation
ever since she watched a video of a
police officer digging his knee into the
neck of george floyd
she'd pledged to become a better white
person by the way
one of the actual reason why this
particular school had pictures of white
kids is because they were able to reach
the parents to ask for permission
it seriously says this right in the
article okay the craziest part of this
article
and it really is indicative of what the
anti-racist movement wants from
white wolf liberals is shut up and
repeat what we tell you
don't think for yourself don't really
try to figure out what you can do pay
robin deangelo ten thousand dollars to
come to your business and yell at you
listen to what ibrahim kennedy tells you
are the systems of oppression and then
dismantle those systems of oppression by
shutting the hell up
right that's what the goal is here to
confuse people so much about what is
racist and what is not racist that you
can do nothing
there are no solutions the purpose that
the feature is not a bug the feature of
this system
is there are no solutions it's a bug if
you provide a solution
because once you've provided a solution
you're shoring up the system the feature
is making you feel bad about yourself
because any solution you provide is
going to be in
insanely and incessantly racist so
here's the best part of the article
so christine tell and a woman named cody
who's an administrator at the preschool
got together to discuss diversity they
were joined at their preschool by
another good friend and teacher named
katie columbine
the three women felt that the pictures
didn't actually show how diverse the
school was
of the 45 students enrolled in the
school this year at least nine had one
parents of color according to their
tally
cody had chosen the pictures because
they were children of parents who worked
at the school
it was easier to get permission for them
she then posted new photos of children
with darker skin
but she knew those changes were
insufficient
how did she know this she knew this
because everything is insufficient she
then posted new photos of children with
darker skin she knew those changes
weren't sufficient only three of the
school students were african-american
how many black baby dolls do we have she
asked we need to get some black baby
dolls
oh i didn't think about that said
columbine the other teacher we have none
but that wasn't intentional
99 of those toys are donated tell
suggested the fact that all the toys
were the same race by happenstance was
an idea worth
thinking about okay so we now know this
was not a racist thing right people just
donated their toys and
tell was like well maybe that's because
the system is even more racist
no matter what the justification is
there's always more work to be done guys
and by work
we mean doing nothing in naval gazing i
think part of our responsibility as
white people is to reflect back on our
own experiences
and what ways we have unconsciously
chosen the white baby doll
said tell okay so this is all naval
gazing we are the white saviors
black people have no agency we need
people like christine
if you need people like christine tell
to save racial america
if you're a black person waiting for
christine to save you're going to be
waiting an awful long time just going to
let you know that right now
okay cody told the other teachers the
floyd video moved her to want to do her
part
to bring unity to this country cody said
she'd spent her adult life trying not to
pay attention to skin color because she
didn't want anyone to be judged by their
race
that would be the reasonable position
now she could not stop paying attention
to a person's skin color
and the injustice it might bring so now
she didn't think about race before now
all she does is think about race
is the country better for this is the
country strong like whose problems have
been solved by this
the answer is no buddies when i'm
driving down the street and there's a
black man walking down the street bam i
look and i go oh wow cody said i say
okay he might be next
okay why are you what i thought that
that was an aspect of racism
right that if you walk down the street
you see a black person you immediately
make a judgment about their situation on
the basis of their race alone
that's kind of racist is it not but no
she wanted to do more than get to
get more diverse baby dolls i seriously
thought about going to north tulsa she
said and knocking on doors
and saying hey i'd really love for your
child to come to preschool here and
we'll give you a full scholarship for it
she said
but is that offensive asked columbin a
37 year old mother of four
because you're only reaching to the
other side and the only reason you're
offering a scholarship is skin color
is that offensive i don't know cody said
now's not the time
tell said so now they're talking about
overtly doing something good
for people who are minority and they're
like now's not the time guys i mean
is that racist for us to do that is it
not racist i don't know i don't know
what the hell's going on but
i'm so scared i'm so scared of being
called racist for doing stuff that's not
remotely racist
columbine the other teacher was nervous
about coming up with ideas to help the
black community
that came from a group of white women
who had few black friends in their lives
and who didn't actively think about race
until the summer
you could lose your job column instead
you don't want to be viewed that way
when you're trying to help
columbine agreed she needed to teach her
children to be kind and stand up when
people seem cruel to others especially
minorities but now
it seemed that friends like tell were
asking her to do uncomfortable things
things that might be taken the wrong way
they were using these terms that seemed
to have just been popularized
white privilege implicit by it
structural racism growing up racism was
never explained to us this way columbine
said
it was never the system it was more of a
prejudice she paused
that is probably also why it's hard as a
white person to know how to help or
speak up or be an advocate for the black
community
but it's our job to speak out tell said
it's our job to hear what is being said
to us and take the time to read a book
or watch a movie that's recommended and
try to put our experience aside and
really try to understand i've done that
columbine said i watched just mercy
i watched the movie about harriet tubman
i watched it with my kids how does that
make life better for anyone in the black
community
how does my not watching a movie keep
them down tell had not fully worked out
the answer to this question
she hoped conversations with white
people would help change votes and
change minds but
sometimes she asked herself how could
she be sure she couldn't be certain
because she wasn't certain of anything
in a month she realized pervasive racism
in the school system and in the prison
system in her family and her friends
and herself the tectonics of what made
it great to be an american seemed to be
shifting and she i had no idea what it
meant
for the future and that is in the end
the point the
end point for all of this is you're
confused about america you think america
is inherently bad you don't know
anything but you know you suck and you
know america sucks
that's the only point of all of this it
doesn't make anybody's life better it
forecloses paths to success
for minority americans it even stops
white people from trying to help black
americans because any solution
is you being paternalistic so all this
is designed to do in the end
is shame white people into feeling bad
enough to give up any sort of agency
to the ibram candies of the world to
give them orders as to how to be an
anti-racist you need a guide
you need a guide through this thicket
this mismatic nonsense that is created
solely for the purpose of tearing down
the system
that's dangerous for black people it's
dangerous for white people because guess
what the american system is damned
phenomenal
it is a phenomenal system the american
system replete with the declaration of
independence values
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness equality before the law
rights that pre-exist government against
your fellow citizen
rights to prevent them from from
infringing upon your rights
those things are great they've created
prosperity they've created wealth
they've created long life all of those
are products of our declaration
the the notion that you have to tear
down the declaration in order to achieve
something better
and that and then in any system aspects
of success like the scientific method
that is tied to subjugation it's
disgusting
it's disgusting and the white idiots who
buy into it
are are pusillanimous cowards anybody
who buys into it is a pusillanimous
coward
okay it's it's it's insane i relegate
the
animus cowardice to the white people
because the white people are the ones
who are being called racist right that's
that's the way that this works
but if you fall for this trick if you
fall for this garbage you're not only an
idiot and a dupe you're making the
country a worse place again i talk about
this at length
in my book how to destroy america in
three easy steps it's just it's
being weaponized so fast and taking over
the culture so fast it's astonishing
it's astonishing
but i guess you can sell any sort of
idiocy so long as you threaten somebody
with the club of calling them a racist
even if they're not a racist
we'll get some more about this in just
one second because you can see it being
internalized and weaponized you've got
ilhan omar
using exactly this logic to suggest all
of her critics are racist you got joe
scarborough writing entire columns about
internalizing his own whiteness and such
we'll get to that in just
one second first if you've got a car
that's taking up space sitting in your
driveway
they don't use that you're paying
insurance on why
you should not get rid of it donate it
to cars for kids you've heard their
jingle you know one
eight seven seven cars for kids k-a-r-s
cars kids right now it's stuck in your
head
forever and it will be stuck in your
head forever until you donate your car
for the children
cars for kids makes the process of
donating your car quick and easy get a
tax deduction and a vacation voucher
it takes just about two minutes they
handle all the details all the paperwork
all you need to do is schedule a pickup
and sign the title pickups are contact
free
you just leave your signed title with
your keys in the car to avoid all of the
unnecessary contact the cars for kids
driver
conveniently picks up your car while
maintaining a safe distance your car
donation it's fast
it's free picked up within 24 hours
often even the same day and cars for
kids will take your car even if it is
not running
again tax deductible and as a special
thank you for donating your car cars for
kids will give you a vacation voucher
good for a three-day
two-night hotels day which is really
awesome so you're doing something great
and you're getting something out of it
doesn't get better than that with cars
for kids you get professional service
convenient pickup
maximum tax deduction a vacation voucher
and a good deed donate today
at carsforkids.org ben that's cars with
a k
k-a-r-s the number four kids.org slash
ben
they'll give you the donation experience
you deserve cars for kids.org
and remember that song will haunt you
the rest of your days unless you check
out carsforkids.org
k-a-r-s cars for kids go check them out
right now carsforkids.org
them all right we're going to get to the
the speed
with which this hideous idiocy is taking
over the country i'll get to that
in just one second first as i've been
mentioning all throughout the show
my new book how to destroy america in
three easy steps it goes on sale tuesday
july 21st 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific
we will be doing a virtual live signing
event on the day of release with your
purchase of a signed copy
you can write in a question which may be
read and answered as i sign your book
live on the air you can pre-order your
signed copy and write in your question
at dailywire.com ben as i've been
talking about the book covers these
fundamentally different visions of
america one vision is unifying the
declaration of independence the
constitution of the united states a
culture of right
a history of greatness the other
disintegrates all the things that tie us
together america's an evil historically
terrible place
the constitution is a document of
subjugation the declaration
is mere papering for hierarchies of
power disintegrationists these are the
people
who are using weapons like the cancel
culture deleting or silencing anyone or
anything that disagrees with them to
build a whole new world order and tear
down the system
from within how to destroy america in
three easy steps details how this
alternative world view has gained so
much cultural ground so quickly
and not and it doesn't just investigate
this it rebuts it which is really the
important part it's the kind of book
that you should buy
for your good hearted liberal friends to
remind them
exactly why we ought to belong in the
same country go check out dailywire.com
to order your signed copy today join my
live signing on tuesday july
21st also if you're not already a daily
wire member you should consider getting
a reader's pass to dailywire.com
great value only three bucks a month
when you sign up you get that first
month for only 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app articles you had free
access to exclusive editorials like the
new one that i've put out specifically
today
on all of this nonsense this national
museum of african-american history and
culture idiocy i put out an entire
column on it today but you can only see
it if you have a reader's past
if you haven't checked out the reader's
past already head on over to
dailywire.com and sign up for just a
buck you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
okay so the the ticket to entry into the
anti-racist world
is to in malice fashion denounce
yourself and to announce your own
goodly vision of the united states if
you believe the united states is a good
place founded on fundamentally
and eternally true values if you believe
that if you believe that america has not
always lived up to that that there are
many flaws and dark
times in american history deeply dark
devastating times in american history
where americans failed to live up to the
vision
of the founding fathers indeed many of
the founding fathers failed to live up
to their own vision
but that america was founded on true
good principles and that the
the striving to fulfill those principles
has created the most powerful
most free country in the history of the
world if you believe that stuff you're
bad and so you have to struggle with
that now and you have to demonstrate
you're struggling and that is the
solution guys the struggle is the
solution
you don't have to actually solve a
problem the struggle is the solution
thus you have joe scarborough
over at msnbc he has a piece in the
washington post today called i still
believe in the american dream but i know
why so many others
don't now listen if you've actually
lived in privation
in the united states if you've actually
lived in abject poverty if you've grown
up in a family
in which education was just not a
priority
and everyone around you was dependent on
government largest i understand that too
i do i've said this in speeches before
if you take somebody from a
deeply devastatingly poor area who has a
broken family structure and you drive
them around beverly hills and you say if
you work hard one day this could be you
right
this house could be yours you can see
why people would look at that and say
well hell i don't believe you
that sounds it sounds ridiculous i
understand that but that's not what joe
scarborough is saying what he is saying
is that the united states is essentially
a caste system
and the system itself is fundamentally
broken in certain ways
so joe scarbrough says he he says my
oldest son then 21 had never seen fear
running across his father's face why
should he have joey's dad after all was
a six foot four inch white man born in a
suburban middle-class home
whose parents were raised in the throes
of the great depression and started
their family during the american
centuries zenith
they bequeathed to their children of
faith in god a good name the unshakeable
belief that anything was possible
through hard work
my election to congress as a young
outsider only served to reinforce the
scarborough family's faith
in the dream then he talks about how his
son nearly
nearly drowned um and the and and he
says you know that feeling of panic
is is now the feeling of panic that
happens for basically all black people
he says i know i am blessed to have had
the luxury of living fearlessly through
the first four decades of my life
unlike my post colleague eugene robinson
i never had to warn my teenage boys how
to behave when stopped by a police
officer
unlike the writer ta-nehisi coates i did
not know the fear that arises from being
born
of a people who control nothing who can
protect nothing
as coates told his son black people love
their children with a kind of obsession
you are all we have
and you come to us endangered okay
immediately buying into that lie that
all black people in america are
endangered it's just a lie there are 42
million black people in the united
states
the average median the median household
income in the united states for black
families is 58 thousand dollars
okay black children in the united states
are not born endangered we are not
living in 1890 we're not living in 1960
we are living in 2020.
so just to just repeat that ta-nehisi
coates makes a damn good living
tanaha seacoats is is a is a product of
a system
that has generated an enormous wealth
and prosperity for ta-nehisi codes
and yet according to tahashi coats all
black children everywhere are living in
a sort of
endangered endangered species situation
in which society is conspiring to crush
them it's a conspiracy theory without
any conspiracy
the streets of west baltimore says joe
scarborough do not allow a child to walk
through life carrying a sense of
invincibility
instead parents harbor an unremitting
dread when their child does something as
mundane as walking to school
and now scarborough is just conflating
problems that are solvable in west
baltimore with the system as a whole
you know why kids fear walking to school
in west baltimore it ain't because of
the cops
the reason the kids fear walking to
school in west baltimore is because
people are getting shot every day on
their way to school in west baltimore
not by the police fathers across the
south side of chicago says joe
scarborough
cannot assure their children that a
faith in god a love of country and a
life filled with hard work will lead
them to the dream why
why i mean seriously why i want to know
i want to know why you can't assure your
kids of that
and what message does it send that you
will not assure your kids of that if
you're not assuring your kids of that
the single worst thing you can do for a
child is no matter how hard you work
you're screwed
right that is the worst thing you can
say to a kid for millions of americans
says joe scarborough that dream appears
to be little more than a white man's
conjuring
designed to conceal a country's sins and
hold its citizens harmless for crimes
committed against black humanity over
the past
400 years and now again if the if the
game here is
that black americans have been
historically victimized in the united
states
and therefore we cannot say to a young
black child growing up in america today
that you have opportunity then that's a
that's an insidious game
those are not the same thing coming from
a historically oppressed people myself i
can say i have lived the freest
god blessed life i could possibly
imagine in this country
and so did my grandparents and so did my
great grandparents coming to this
country
you know the the the the the very idea
that everybody who's being born in 2020
is subjected
to the same sorts of evil systems of
repression that existed 60 years ago
is patently insane but it has become a
wrote article of faith and the reason
scarborough is writing all this is not
to provide a solution
at no point does he provide a solution
in this column instead
we now know that joe scarborough is a
good person because he read ta-nehisi
coates guys
he read between the world and me and
that means that joe scarborough has now
been alleviated
of all responsibility he's mouthed the
words
he's mouthed them he says as coates
wrote in between the world and me
maybe the most overrated book ever
written americans should take their
exceptionalism seriously and subject the
country to an exceptional moral standard
the journey can only end when every
citizen is raised free of fear and
filled with the same dream that so many
of us take for granted but what if
what if there's an entire side of the
culture a disintegrationist culture
that believes it is negative and wrong
to teach your children that the dream is
even possible
the dream itself teaching your kids
about the dream it makes you an
assimilationist
this is what joe scarborough doesn't
understand or doesn't wish to understand
it doesn't matter how many
times he says that the dream is not
available to everyone and so we must
make the dream more available
the dream is the target okay the the
people
who are pushing this anti-racist
redefinition they believe
that even the idea of the american dream
is racist and all the methodologies to
achieve success within that dream are
bad joe scarborough will always be part
of the enemy contingent to these folks
which joe should acknowledge
okay no matter what joe does he can he
can retain his coats
before his kids to bed at night is a
catechism it will not matter one iota so
long as he keeps saying that america is
an exceptional place in a good place
but all this also allows enormous
credibility for people like ilhan omar
who talks about ripping down the system
and then says that anybody who
criticizes her is racist right which
again
relies on this redefinition because if
she says rip down the system you say
well that sounds kind of terrible
i didn't weren't you given opportunity
el hanomar didn't you immigrate to the
united states at age 12
from the hellscape that is somalia and
then you were elected to congress
right i mean like that's a pretty great
pretty damn great american success story
shouldn't you be a little bit grateful
for the system if you say that you're a
racist according to elhan omar
so she says she quotes herself talking
about how she wanted to tear down the
system right she said we are not merely
fighting to tear down systems of
oppression in the criminal justice
system we're fighting to tear down
systems of oppression that exist in
housing and education and healthcare and
employment
in the very air we breathe as long as
our economic
and political systems prioritize profit
without considering who is profiting
and who is being shot out we will
perpetuate this inequality so we cannot
stop at the criminal justice system we
must begin the work of dismantling the
whole system of oppression wherever we
find it
which sounds an awful like awful lot
like the entire system needs to be torn
down
so according to ilhan omar if you quote
her you're bad now right this is her
this is her usual routine
and if you if you note that she's an
anti-semite who believes that the jews
control world money
it's all about the benjamins israel
support and all of us then that's
because you're a racist
so she says the criticism she's my she
says the criticism
was something i'd become accustomed to
as a black muslim woman in public life
okay no it's not about you being a black
muslim woman in public life it's about
the fact that you said something
absolutely terrible and that the
american system should not be torn down
i would say this about white people i
did okay i've done an entire podcast and
robin d'angelo saying the same stuff
but the nice thing for ilhan omar is
because of her identity she can now
claim that if you criticize her opinion
you're criticizing her race
which is absolute nonsense she says this
is something female leaders and leaders
of color have dealt with for years
hillary clinton's every move was
scrutinized barack obama was hounded by
claims he was a muslim and not born in
the united states keith ellison was
subject to an anti-muslim smear campaign
when he ran for democratic party chair
fear of the other
stems i believe from the myth of
scarcity pitting minority groups against
one another in a fight for scraps
by the way the only people who talk like
this are people of the left that america
is
is not a growing pie it's about fighting
for the scraps and all part of this
tearing down the system routine now the
nice thing
also is that this means that you can
basically be as racist as antsy semitic
as you want to be so long as you have
the right opinions
so yesterday nick cannon who i guess is
a nickelodeon host haven't paid much
attention to him uh he lost his job at
viacom cbs after he went on a podcast
and suggested that white people were
devils which apparently by the way did
not earn chiding from viacom cbs he
suggested
that the jews were basically in control
of everything
it was it was just a bunch of louis
farrakhan
based anti-semitic conspiracy nonsense
and he got fired for it right
and then he put out an apology which is
well taken like i think that when people
put out apologies
we should generally accept the apology
you know absent evidence to
to suggest that they are not truly
apologizing for what they've done that
is wrong
but there are people like major people
who came out of the woodwork to support
him
they came out of the woodwork to support
nick cannon's openly answers medical
openly anti-white statements
in fact charlemagne the god right went
on his went on his
podcast and he suggested that nick
cannon's firing shows that the jews have
the power right he'll get away with it
right every
the bottom line is nick cannon will get
his job back right charlemagne the god
doing this like it's amazing it's
amazing imagine if white people came out
defending like the conspiracy the
anti-semitic conspiracy theorizing of
david duke
they would be correctly thrown out of
congress right i mean if you even
express
sentiments approaching that like steve
king's in iowa many of us max out to
your opponent
when i say many of us i mean i led the
way on that one right charlemagne the
god is out there openly defending it
cannon
p diddy offered him a job through
charlemagne the god defending nick
cannon
by saying you know he said that the jews
have all the power him being fired shows
the jews have all the power
so um when does charlemagne the god
actually have to answer for this bit of
anti-semitism
listen nick is my guy i hate it had to
be him but that's what you can do when
you have the power and if there's one
thing jewish people have showed us
if they have the power i can't wait
until the day black people are able to
fire people
for saying things about us that we deem
racist we can barely get cops fired
for actually killing us they fired nick
for referencing a theory written by
a psychologist okay on racism also
though
if you're gonna have that conversation
have it with a jewish scholar
have it with a rabbi have it with
someone from that community so anything
you say that's not accurate they can
correct you
okay that's insane okay so charlemagne
got openly saying it's because the jews
have the power
well the beautiful thing about
conspiracy theories is because they are
unfalsifiable you can say
pretty much anything right the jews are
the jews are evil and have all the power
you get fired because that's a bad thing
to say
and then the comeback is because the
jews have all the power
p diddy comes out he says nick cannon
come home to revolt tv
truly black owned we got your back and
love you and what you have done for the
culture we are for our people first
for us by us let's go we are for our
people first for us by us let's go
but remember that's not racist true
racism is just standing up for a free
system in which everybody has
opportunity
that's true racism okay it's time for a
quick thing
that i like we have reached that point
brought to you by the benham brothers
learn how to own a business without it
owning you get a 15
discount right now on the benton
brothers new course expert ownership at
bennenbrothers.com once again that's
benhambrothers.com
talent go check out the benham brothers
new course expert ownership
benhambrothers.com
talent okay time for a quick thing that
i like which we haven't done in quite a
while
so i mentioned briefly on the show
yesterday the movie mr jones
i frankly could not believe that this
movie was made so the movies about
gareth jones gareth jones
was the journalist who first reported on
the halatomar the the
murder and the starvation of millions of
ukrainians
ukrainian farmers during the five-year
plan of joseph stalin
that was intended to industrialize the
soviet union by basically depriving
everybody of grain
in ukraine and starving them to death it
resulted in
literal cannibalism i mean people eating
their family and friends because they
had no food
it resulted in mass starvation resulted
in millions of people dying
it was horrifying okay so this movie is
not just about gareth jones reporting on
it and the evils of the soviet union
it's also about the evils of the new
york times because walter durante was
the pulitzer prize-winning reporter
the fiction writing pulitzer
prize-winning reporter yes
nothing has changed much who decided it
was more worthwhile to back the
narrative that the soviet union was a
godsend then to report on the fact that
the soviet union was slaughtering
via starvation millions and millions of
people in ukraine here's a little bit of
the trailer
now there's nothing but wheat fields
grain is stalin's gold
who gives the agenda now i don't have an
agenda unless you call truth
and agenda yes but who's truth
what were you doing the others come
forward what's being done here
will transform mankind we can still do
something new we cannot let stalin get
away with this what do you expect me to
do exactly
the soviet union is not the workers
paradise
that was promised it is not
the great experiment that you read about
in the press
the movies okay and i kept waiting for
the sucker punch
but the movie goes right at it i mean
there's there's a full scene
in which gareth jones is talking with
sort of an acolyte
of walter durante and she says listen
the cause is really important right
communism is the dream of the future and
you know there has to be time to
allow the progress to be achieved and he
says
people are being murdered right you're
justifying murder
and it finally occurs to her that this
is the case and walter durante is
is really revealed in all of his true
glory i mean like in every way
in this film and it just it is
demonstrative of what happens
when journalists become so invested in
their cause they're willing to falsify
the facts and cover up evil
and this is unfortunately that has not
changed not one iota one of the
modern movements that we are watching in
journalism right now is the attempt
to not prioritize truth but to
prioritize my truth
there's a scene in this film with gareth
jones the character
where where he is talking about the
importance of journalism he says
journalism is the quest for the truth
and
the person he's talking to says well
there are many facets of truth he says
no there's just like objective fact and
then there's a lot of opinion which is
something i've said myself
and he and and that's the perspective of
the film which is what makes it a great
film
right because the fact is that when
journalists become so invested in the
cause that they have decided to ignore
all countervailing evidence they're no
longer journalists they are now
activists
this is what's happening over the new
york times where the where the woke
now run the place where the quest for
truth has become completely secondary to
the idea that they are the repositories
of
all knowledge and all orthodoxy and they
are cramming it down from above it has
not changed one
iota this is not changed one iota from
walter durrante to nicole hannah jones
when the narrative matters more than the
facts ugly things emerge
and nicole hannah jones just wanna
appeal a surprise just like walter
durante
for writing a bit of fiction walter
durrancy won a pulitzer prize for
suggesting that stalin's
russia was the greatest place on earth
and that ukraine was disneyland
nicole hannah jones just won a pulitzer
prize for suggesting that america is a
repository of all evil
was founded and steeped in evil that the
true founding of america was 1619 not
she wrote it in her own fact challenged
manner she is by the way a conspiracy
theorist on a variety of topics
doesn't matter the narrative above all
wesley lowry the former washington post
reporter has basically decided
that it's time to ditch all notions of
objective journalism that what we need
more is more of the nicole hannah jones
style of journalism we need more opinion
journalism but they won't label it
opinion journalism they will just label
it morally right journalism
see the difference between what we do
here at daily wire and what they do over
at the new york times now
or what they are doing in the wesley
lowry world is that i will openly tell
you
my assumptions i will openly tell you my
political point of view and i will tell
you that if you want
to form your own viewpoint you should
listen to my show and then you should go
listen to pod save america
you should read daily wire and then you
should go read huffington post you
should read a variety of viewpoints and
then come away
with your own perspective on the issue
you shouldn't just swallow everything
hook line and sinker because i'm overt
about my own biases
what the sort of moral the moral betters
in journalism say
is there is no countervailing point of
view that is worth discussing they will
openly say this
they will say we can't have false
balance in which our views are pitted
against other views because our views
are so eminently right
our views are so eminently true the
narrative is just that important so we
can't allow
a countervailing narrative to get out
there and so
they will they will ignore information
they will falsify
information it this is the world of
journalism
that exists in the here and now that
doesn't mean there aren't good
journalists
at these institutions there are there
are good journalists at the washington
post there are good journalists over at
the new york times
it means the institutions have decided
as institutions to go back to the bad
old days of walter durante
and to reward the people who openly
acknowledge what they are doing at least
walter durrante
was was lying to his superiors i mean
walter durrance was just telling his
superior stuff that wasn't true
i don't think anybody in the new york
times is lying to the their superiors i
think they're just
badgering their superiors the editors of
the new york times are not in control of
the new york times
pinch souls burger is not in control of
the new york times nicole hannah jones
is in charge of the new york times
so if you worry about the future of
journalism if you worry about the
the idea that the narrative ought to
trump the fact and if you worry that
the woke are so invested in the
narrative they can't give you the truth
you should check out the movie mr jones
it is excellent
excellent film by the way i will note
that it is it is amusing to me
that it only took like 70 years after
salon died for people in hollywood to
start recognizing stalin was a bad man
there have been a couple movies made in
the last three years recognizing that
stalinism was actually quite evil
it only took them like 70 years on that
one so i'm glad that they finally came
around in hollywood to the perspective
that stalin was indeed one of history's
great monsters alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content in the meantime
go pre-order a copy of my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps or
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stephens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
kanye drops out of the race president
trump dumps his campaign manager and
twitter gets hacked
check it out on the michael knoll show
you